yes and awakening has happened indeed
holy shower you know me
big Star Wars fans when a new trailer
for the new JJ Abrams directed Star Wars
movie comes out you were getting video
on that this dress is actually a lot
more than I thought it was gonna be I
thought it was just gonna be like a
landscape of Tatooine you see the two
suns and then someone walks out and
whips out a lightsaber and that'd be it
this shows actually a bit more than that
first it starts up well you do see
tattooing like everyone unanimously
knows the first shot of this trailer was
going to be tattooing we just all knew
that you hear this voice go there has
been an awakening have you felt it a
voice that sounds an awful lot like the
batch of gumbo I'm not saying it is
Benedict Cumberbatch I'm just saying if
I had a gun to my head zone who does
that sound like ever like Benedict
Cumberbatch although it sounds like him
at first mid when he says the dark side
and the light later on it doesn't sound
like him anymore
it makes me feel like it's someone doing
a voice it just sounds a lot like
Benedict Cumberbatch's voice also and
this is just me analysing the [ __ ] out
of it if you listen to how it sounds it
sounds like he's talking with his teeth
together like this summer bash when he
talks and does his cumbrous voice he
doesn't sound like that his mouth was
open wolf goes I don't know that it
might be any circus I just doll him said
it's cool voice though but the first
person you see popping to the frame on
that shot of tattooing is John boyega
and he looks around he's walking you
like leading the stormtroopers outfit so
you're like oh you're a stormtrooper
although oh oh let's just live in an
alternate dimension where Star Wars is
coming out for the first out of 1977
Star Wars movie but we also have the
internet and I do videos and really
stretch your mind on this [ __ ] anyhow
imagine this is a shot in the trailer I
would be talking to you right now be
like the good stormtrooper it wasn't a
story was just wearing the uniform one
so John boyega might not be a
stormtrooper he might just be wearing a
stormtroopers uniform but what if he is
a stormtrooper but he's force sensitive
and so Luke's like hey I'll teach you
we've never seen that before we haven't
seen that you know you work for the
Empire but your force sensitive and
you're not evil so I will teach you the
ways of the force not in a movie anyway
if he's not for since if he is just a
stormtrooper John boyega there's no
shame in that so my favorite characters
from Star Wars do not have the force
boba fett Han Solo Lando yeah I
gravitate towards the Pirates and you
see the stormtroopers in their helmets
look a little different but ultimately
stormtrooper masks stay with the x-wing
pilot uniforms or helmets are a little
different but all
you look at it you're like that's an
x-wing pilot the thing I loved about
this trailer is with every shot there
was a Star Wars sound effect whether it
be that speeder that chick gets on is
over well the droids are better at the
sound effects brought back my nostalgia
stay with the concept that it is Star
Wars but you can tell the camera work
and the camera shots in this trailer
you're like this is not directed by
George Lucas it's completely different
vibe it has grit that's seen where John
boyega pops into frame and then he looks
over and starts walking the camera
follows him over it's just it's a shot
that I'm like I don't think George Lucas
would have shot it that way if you like
the prequels that's fine I am just
illustrating to you it does feel
different at least from what we saw in
the minute and a half trailer but then
you hear that same boys which again now
it doesn't sound like Cumberbatch as
much it shows this hooded figure in a
black robe and he blocks out his
lightsabers I'll be but what I love
about this [ __ ] is when that lightsaber
popped out is like you feel it like oh
man that thing means business it felt
like when the enterprise and the ships
went into war up in the Abrams Star Trek
movie how we were used to a gun this was
all bish and they're just gone that's
the kind of force this lightsaber gave
out when it just BAM popped out some odd
reason Abrams loves ah he's like I like
people feeling the effect of something
going from A to B now I've seen some
hate comments on the fact that this
lightsaber has a lightsaber hilt it's
right it looks like Excalibur it's like
oh yeah and Uriel BAM eat your heart out
Aragorn just [ __ ] have the same [ __ ] now
but it's a lightsaber
it's the lightsaber and then you see the
two lightsaber hilts coming off the side
which I think that's a fine design I've
always thought that with your lightsaber
fighting some was like oh you know it
would suck no hilt yeah this was like
you know it sucks what what sucks that's
right that's my hilt and my sword is
effing enormous so watch this what
you're seven feet away drop do you have
anyway look guess what it doesn't matter
so I'm gonna sit with a new sword I'm
always down with new lightsaber designs
removing Darth Maul had the double-sided
life sterols like that thing's gonna be
business and it was business in the
phantom in is it made for a pretty sweet
fight I would just think that in an
order comprised of many different
cultures and many different alien races
a lot of them have it in their bones and
genetics to fight a certain way there
would be different lightsaber styles out
there and then it happens it shows the
Millennium Falcon's all flying the
cameras falling rattle stowed boys
nothing but Star Wars it's flying ct2
Tie Fighters off
why right by and the title comes on Star
Wars The Force awakens and I was like
all right let's play that again and then
I did that 78 more times now I'm making
a video about it I'm really pumped for
this movie this is a teaser trailer like
I've always said a teaser trailer is a
chance for the director kind of to show
us all where the vibe of the movie is
going this is a trailer for a movie that
comes out a year from now so all we
needed to know was the vibe we've got a
little more than I wanted so that's
always a nice bonus and I feel the vibe
of the movie if the point of a trailers
to get people excited yes I'm absolutely
excited for this movie I probably could
have told you day before yesterday that
yes this trailer is probably gonna end
with us seeing the Millennium Falcon in
the Star Wars theme playing and that I
feel like it's like it's that a cheap
shot but it's the coolest cheap shot
ever
that's what we wanted to say the
voice-over in this movie makes me think
of like when he's like oh there's been
an awakening the dark side of the force
and the light again I'm like why the
force awakens is this the force of sleep
then I'll just go away is it coming back
why is it awakening what's happening so
Star Wars The Force awakens trailer have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more